salut je m'appelle fabien olicard dans
ce format nous faisons un focus sur un
point en particulier du cerveau dans
l'épisode précédent nous avons fait le
premier numéro spécial été voici donc le
deuxième bienvenue dans matière
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui
[Musique]
dans cet épisode nous allons vivre
quatre expériences expérience une un
corps en or expérience 2 devenez le
magicien de la soirée deux expériences 3
c'est à vous expérience 4 devenez le roi
du qui s le tout avec la présence très
appréciée de lola de milice
vous avez compris que aujourd'hui vous
êtes dans un matière grise un peu plus
fun le deuxième et dernier épisode piles
et j'ai tourné spécialement pour ne pas
vous oublier cet été en quatre
expériences vous allez débloquer pas
moins de sept compétences pour votre
cerveau certaine nous seront très utiles
et d'autres vont juste vous permettre
d'impressionner un peu les gens ou de
faire rire tout le monde cet été avant
de passer aux petits trucs sympas et fun
que diriez-vous de retenir n'importe
quelle information facilement sans
entraînement pratique pour noter sa
liste de courses en vacances ou un
numéro de téléphone lorsqu'on n'a pas de
quoi écrire il ya une technique pour ça
c'est celle du palais du corps
je me suis dit quand même vous pouvez
quand même donner un outil pratique pour
les vacances c'est un truc de mémoire et
c'est que j'adore la mémoire et vous
voilà je la prends mais le problème des
mecs cadors quelque chose comme ça c'est
que à chaque fois je leur apprend des
trucs compliqués qui demande beaucoup
d'entraînement et c'est donc là je me
suis creusé la tête pour un truc facile
genre imagine t en vacances attends toi
ouais salue tous à l aula tu peux noter
le numéro de téléphone ce qui veux ta
pâte à papier tu n'as pas de crayon tu
le retient comment je leur tiens pas
exactement et je suis cette personne
nouvelles mises en situation oui le la
tiens je te donne la liste de courses
retient là et va faire des courses oh
j'ai oublié les eaux parce que tu avais
rien pour noter évidemment moi je vais
t'apprendre à noter avec ta tête hu
alors en bray c'est très rare qu'on
n'ait rien pour noter mais en vrai ça
arrive ah non non ça m'arrive très
fréquemment puisque l' usage du stylo
wii est décédé et que en vacances on
oublie très fréquemment son téléphone je
crois que je vais dire le visage de mon
cerveau
illégalement je te donne une liste de
courses et essaye de la retenir de
retenir un maximum comme ça franquet et
après on fera un comparatif une fois que
tu connaîtras la méthode en gros tu vas
te planter
alors une bouée une si un signe l'animal
ne planche à voile à 9 noeuds bûche de
noël j'ai des pasdaran dans un livre des
québécois d'éteindre hockey un livre des
bougies et un parpaing qui achètent
le même gars qui achètent en même temps
une planche à voile et une bûche de noël
vraiment je ne saurais très belle en
août bon ok bien sûr qu'est-ce que
qu'est ce que tu as retenu comme ça en
vrac un signe oui une bouée oui une si
oui
j'ai une planche à voile oui et encore
une lampe non une ampoule non pré ampli
mais pour toutes avec trinité de
traînards ans tu vis tu viens de prouver
alors ça n'a rien à voir avec cette
expérience tu viens de prouver le côté
associatif du cerveau en fait j'ai dit
une bougie avis donc c'est de la limite
donc en train de me dire plein de choses
qu'on est en rapport avec la lumière il
est drôle sur un dock une bougie donc
une chose m'a dit tu me l'a dit donc
j'ai pas retenir c'est pas mal parce que
je pense que tu étais à la moitié voire
aux trois quarts tu vois si je devais
laisser chercher plus longtemps
maintenant maintenant si on parle
français comment retenir tout ça
facilement grâce au palais mental est ce
que tu connais la technique du palais
mental oui tu me l'avait apprise gbe en
spectacle en plus sympa c'est vrai j'en
fait j'avoue je suis allé plusieurs fois
le voir en spectacle venez-y n'est pas
les recettes personne ne peut pas en
core 2 duo mais on a chacun spectacle
est bien son image je suis là comme il
est intelligent je n'ai pas de mémoire
de mec qui chante et ne sais pas j'ai
dit et je sais qu'ils vont me tuer le
duo a pas les mental ça vient des grecs
c'était une technique de mémoire pour se
rappeler des choses en les disposant
dans des lieux imaginaires etc et c'est
d'ailleurs pour ça qu'on dit dans la vie
courante en premier lieu je vais faire
ça en deuxième le jeu a causé par des
palais manteau il ya un palais mental
que tu auras toujours sur toi en temps
normal c'est le palais mental de ton
corps oui et du coup il n'y a pas besoin
d'entraînement comment ça fonctionne
comme ceux-ci jean-jacques mais tu as
dessinée super vite je dessine
extrêmement rapidement et c'est surtout
de nikki le feu qui ont leur masse le
plus de mental du corps il fonctionne
comme ça on va juste avoir dix spots
différents qui sont la tête et après
c'est toujours droite gauche ted oreille
droite oreille gauche bras droit bras
gauche ventre jambe droite jambe gauche
pied droit pied gauche et ensuite il
suffit d'associer des choses par
l'imaginaire pour les retenir du coup je
vais te faire retenir cette liste en
utilisant le petit palais mentale du
corps vous pouvez essayer de le faire en
même temps vous allez voir c'est sa
demande pas trop d'entraînement une
petite pression quand même ça veut dire
que si j'arrive pas c'est que j'ai
vraiment un cerveau très long malin
parce qu'on peut faire du montage
enfin c'est la bouée et en un toi tu va
déposer sur ta tête ok donc tu imagines
avoir une bouée sur ta tête alors tu
peux tu imaginer que ta tête et enfoncer
dans une boîte tu vois et ce qui est
cool c'est que les vrais souvenirs où
les choses imaginer sont traités de la
même manière pour le cerveau donc ça tue
à retenir ok donc t'as vu ta tête dans
la boue et c'est la tête d'un vrai
hockey en deux c'est une scie et en deux
c'est l'oreille gauche donc tu peux
vraiment imaginé que tu es en train de
te sied l'oreille gauche tu peux même
faire le geste savard a ajouté la
mémoire du corps etc bon ok en trois
pour l'oreille droite c'est un signe
alors là je ne sais pas m'arrêter régine
moi j'ai retenu tout à l'heure parce que
il fut en tant que tu m'avais appris à
des fois que condensé des mots pour les
retenir oui et je me suis dit s'ils
signent ah oui les signes symétrie un
jour de simba d'ailleurs là tu pourrais
dire je sylla et du coup ça saigne celle
ci à celle là bas à l'exercice est vendu
le quatrième c'est une planche à voile
donc là on est sur le bras gauche alors
que je ne sais pas ce que tu vas faire
de ça mais tu m'as dit que c'était quoi
déjà comme jay sa part très très mal
cette ct par kwh pour sa voix une
planche à voile le bras gauche je ne
sais pas si on pousse à
aller ou non mais je fais comme ça sur
une planche avant donc je tend le bras
gauche pour l équilibre dans ses très
bons jeux
buzz en même temps qu'est ce qu'il veut
faire
moi j'imagine est plutôt un tatouage de
planche à voile et un tatouage je
planche à voile tu vois le bras droit on
met quoi dessus on met un oeuf
ah ouais tu le casque à casque avec me
koubbi
ça ça marche un set c'est la bûche de
noël c'est le à leur entrain à mon avis
oui la bûche de noël au ventre exact moi
je la mange et tu la manges y avait dans
ton ventre sa part me puisse en cette
jambe gauche des termes comme des
tatouages de temps à but non mais si tu
peux te mettre des timbres comme ça je
me colle dakar tu vois la mémoire du
corps en fait ce qui est cool avec le
pad et mentale du corps c'est que tu as
la mémoire corporelle avec donc ok là
d'éteindre d'accord dans huit un livre
pour la jambe droite 1,8 un livre moi
j'imagine j'imaginerais le livre comme
ma jambe comme un marque page d'un livre
géant auxquel plus des images elles sont
chaudes ou niasse rosiane ça va ok c'est
une bougie pour le pied gauche à
j'imagine marché sur une bougie allumée
à lui mais c'est drôle parce qu'alors
moi j'imagine et mes doigts de pied
gauche écarté avec des bougies entre
chaque away nom alors je pense c'est
parce que mon palais notre mental est
déformé d'une expérience que j'ai vu ta
une discipline ans je crois que c'est en
écosse ou en irlande où on fait plein de
bougies qui sont mises les unes à côté
des autres et les mecs ont des
chaussures ou les nanas ont des
chaussures particulière et ils éteignent
les bougies en faisant ça ils doivent on
éteindra maximinois et je couds
récemment jazia des leurs réseaux
sociaux et un club de ce qui sera en
parler en public
du coup j'imagine vraiment le cas faire
des gosses c'est énorme je veux le nom
de ça
et en dise pied droit là ça me tombe
dessus en femme au direct donc là tu as
retenu dix choses sans s'en rendre
compte je te mets ça juste pour que tu
te rappelles de l'ordre dans lequel on a
mémorisé les choses qu'est ce que tu as
sur la tête une boîte qu'est ce que tu
as à l'oreille gauche ainsi qu'est ce
qui se passe du coup à l'oreille droite
je saigne je signe qu'est ce que tu as
sur le bras gauche une planche à voile à
vos bras droit aux [ __ ] attend bras
droit à temps bras droit qu'est ce que
l'ofs exact le baby boom et ibo cheick
109 voix séparant cran 6 la bûche de
noël le 7 janvier gauche les timbres oui
le livre t'as vu ta fait sa direction et
le livre à droite 9 la bougie oui des
disques le parpaing j'ai tout retenu tu
as vu à quel point c'est simple jamais
entraîné de sa est le pire des le pire
du pire c'est que dans deux heures quand
tu rentres chez toi si tu te dis jamais
quoi sur la tête tu vas repenser à la
boue et ça ça se perd et c'est des
images assez des images qui restent et
après tu peux retenir un numéro de
téléphone comme ça très facilement parce
que imagine la boue et ça ressemble un
peu à 1 0 donc tu pourrais dire zéro tu
vois et puis l'oreille gauche c'était
une scie donc tu pourrais dire 6,06 tu
vois l'oreille droite c'est un signe le
signe c'est un peu la forme d'un 2 donc
ça aurait pu être le 2 ce que je veux
dire c'est que si vous imaginez des
objets qui ressemble si tu peux tu iras
d instruction rapide exactement tu peux
retenir un peu ce que tu veux avec sa
table et quoi au bras droit j'avais un
neuf
que vous utilisiez déjà des méthodes
nemo technique ou pas vous aurez
toujours sur vous ce petit palais
mentale temporaire qui est très pratique
et qui ne demande quasiment aucun
entraînement très pratique aussi dans
les jeux comme time's up vous allez voir
trop fait cet épisode de l'été est
également sponsorisé par moi même il ya
plus de surprises
bonjour je suis jean michel jarre et je
suis n'y ait plus jean-michel jardinier
aujourd'hui je vais vous montrer comment
bien entretenir votre femme ou si vous
la rosée toutes les semaines d'un like
sur ces vidéos courant mais ces
premières fleurs feront leur apparition
je veux la rose un petit peu je la rose
un petit peu
première fleur qui sont en fait des
livres commençons tout doucement à
caresser le fab ou pour faire grandir
son pistil nombreux toits tucat restons
piste il
s'exprime pas bien si je te coupe où
pourrais je te retrouver si tu veux un
couple tu peux me mettre dans des
librairies ou des fnac ou des culturales
pour faire des dédicaces où tu peux me
déposer dans des théâtres pour que je
termine ma tournée de mon spectacle
singularité comme dans toutes ces villes
là avec la grosse tête à la fin au
zénith de paris et de toute manière
après quoi qu'il arrive si tu veux pas
venir me voir en spectacle et que tu
veux juste me dire regarde ma fleur est
prête mon nouveau livre lentilles guide
de la manipulation sorti au mois de mai
dernier il te permettra de reprendre le
pouvoir sans prendre celui des autres un
excellent livre sur la manipulation
respire le
quelle belle petite fleur
l'été c'est sûrement la période où l'on
joue le plus dans l'épisode précédent
nous avons vu des tours très simple à
base de cartes mais très bluffant
aujourd'hui nous allons voir des petits
effets magiques de débutant avec dédé
mais tout aussi bluffant qui vont
fonctionner que si vous vous entraînez
avant et que vous gardez ensuite le
secret sans le dévoiler à vos
spectateurs la magie peut se transmettre
comme aujourd'hui mais elle n'existe que
lorsqu'elle est bien traité et si vous
voulez aller plus loin je vous
recommande les livres que vous trouverez
dans les boutiques de magie
donc des tours de magie là de béni oui
tu vas pouvoir impressionner ta famille
tu sais je j'ai hâte que vraiment c'est
pas du tout le plus que tu fasses des
gros concerts des gros spectacle des
[ __ ] de vidéos ça s'est dit
impressionné par an sont blasés que je
connaisse fabien olicard à sa rencontre
et céline dion pour eux c'est rien par
ailleurs apparaître un petit tour de
magie avec un dé là tu peux marquer des
points ce qui reste de d'abord
l'héritage c'est ça
oui comprend trois tours de magie qui
sont assez simples à faire avec un des
jeux télé fait d'abord et après je
t'explique comment les refaire donc
derrière le linge et 1,6 hockey derrière
le 6 g11 donc derrière le linge et 1,6
et derrière le 6 juin et derrière le un
g1 sinon g15 et derrière le 5 juin ça
c'est impressionnant ça ça fait bugger
ouais ok derrière le cinquième fois un
jeu encore et encore un derrière le 5 il
ya un deux noms à deux derrière le droit
et ça ça messieurs dames et ça c'est
très facile à faire et ça marche très
bien alors tu peux nourrir ton tour en
disant quelque chose qui est
complètement vrai l'est des îles sont
pas fabriqués au hasard il ya une règle
chez tous les fabricants de des depuis
toujours c'est que les faces opposées
d'un des fonds toujours cet air est donc
derrière le 2 tu as le 5 ça fait 7
derrière le un talent 6 ça fait 7 et
derrière le 4 tab 3 ça fait cet achat
n'est pas du tout cette règle et ça
permet de nourrir ton tour est de dire
et comme ça fait toujours recette
derrière le ingère si derrière le 6 juin
mais des fois derrière le un g13 est
derrière le 3g 1-1 donc en fait ma règle
a conclu parce que là tu fais ton petit
rixe de magie donc le trx de magie est
très simple je fais ce mouvement
incroyablement compliqué comme c'est
très anciens poussins d'aix en sommes
exactement avec un quart de rotation
comme ça car de rotation qui te permet
en fait de changer la face du terme est
bien sûr je perds tu prends le dès que
tu veux et on va essayer de le faire
ensemble donc là toi tu es tout côté
quatre noms mais je me régalais insiste
donc la table un de l'autre côté donc tu
peux retourner le foyer normalement et
ça fait voir le 6 ensuite ça fait voir
le 1 et ensuite là tu vas juste faire ce
petit mouvement là absolument pas alors
regarde tu mets le pousse bien en bas
vous pouvez regarder pour vous aussi le
pousse bien en bas l'index bien au
dessus ok et maintenant il ya juste
l'index qui va venir le décalé comme ça
vers l'avant exact chez decca juste oui
hélas à 35 hockey à temps je pense que
je suis un peu mal positionné mais en
vrai ce que tu vas faire ça ne t'a pas
le mouvement complet c'est que là je
t'apprends juste à faire ce move mais en
fait c'est le 3 que tu vas faire voir
aux spectateurs ou toi le 2 en
l'occurrence l'acte tu tournes s'attelle
2 essais 2 tu vas faire voir aux
spectateurs et comme en âge il ya une
règle on va appliquer cette règle un
petit mouvement est caché par un gros
mouvement donc si tu faisais que ça les
gens ils le verraient même quand un gars
derrière sa caméra encore dit c'est vrai
si tu fais que ce petit mouvement les
gens ils me croirez pas mais le fait que
tu le fasses pendant son déplacement qui
rapide lui là par contre on ne voit pas
ok j'ai compris c'est que j'ai vraiment
bien compris alors à temps bonjour vous
êtes magiciens ben oui j'ai une clause
sur le terrain apparemment en patinant
pas car je suis un saltimbanque bien sûr
il y a un absolument et derrière le zinc
est ce qu'il ya un 6 1 6 tout à fait un
oui si tout à fait mais des fois il faut
y aller en boîte c'est très très bien
c'est vrai mais oui c'est très très bien
la caméra suit là de très bien toi tu
fais un 6 1 6 1 2 1 2 comme ça et après
tu peux revenir sans refaire le
mouvement donc tu rajoutes un truc parce
que l'amérique il s'agit même pas pensé
tu vois ça c'est incroyable messieurs
dames les bombes latines ruf l'un d'eux
il ya un deuxième tricks que j'aime bien
par contre en avec l'aider je me
retournais faut pas que je vois ce que
tu fais d'accord ok toi tu vas m
le des dents sur la face que tu veux
après temps mettra un autre sur la face
que tu veux que tu va empiler d'accord
et tu vas caché l'ensemble en mettant
encore sur la face que tu veux et après
tu tu peux cacher un jeu comme cela si
tu veux ok alors chers amis nous allons
tester ma vision à rayons x donc là tu
es en train de mettre un dé et d'en
mettre un deuxième au dessus sur les
phases que tu veux et tu vas mettre le
troisième au dessus sur la presse que tu
veux c'est ça oui ok moi je vais juste
pénétrer avec mon regard cette pile 2d
pour additionner ensemble tous les
chiffres qui sont cachés streib le fond
c'est bon tu me crois genou droit ok
bouge pas tant faut juste que je regarde
le dessus de la pile pour pouvoir mon
fond c'est dedans ok ok ok je récupère
toutes les images que j'ai deux cd et ça
fait 19 la somme de tous les chiffres
qui sont cachés ça fait 19 c'est
incroyable que tu me crois pas je ne
sais pas regarde tous les chiffres qui
sont cachés donc
plus de ça fait 7 + 5
donc ça fait douze +4 7 et 16 17 18 19
ah ouais mais moi je suis nul en calcul
mental gradient fallait me dire qu'il
fallait réviser avant la du coup comment
ça fonctionne je pense que vous ne savez
pas encore mais vous devriez le savoir
et c'est ça que j'adore dans cette
cour-là c'est que même en expliquant
comment il fonctionne vous le voyez pas
de seconde après quand je le fais tout à
l'heure je vous ai expliqué que la somme
des phases de chaque dessin faisait 7 5
et 2 ça fait cette année oui tu croyais
car ça fait 7 donc quand tu fais une
pile de d je sais que tu as pile quoi
qu'il arrive de tous les chiffres au
dessus ou en dessous ça fait 21 n'est
pas le choix donc si je fais 21 - le
premier chiffre qu'on voit toi 7 et si
on rate deux mois ils étaient 2 2 24 21
- 2 19 donc je sais que la somme elle
fera 19 aussi bête que ça donc vous
pouvez faire avec 2d vous pouvez le
faire avec 4 des etc vous savez juste
que là ça me dépasse cachée d'un dess
après 7 alors petits conseils quand même
faites pas ce tour bourré
potentiellement et surtout avant d'avoir
expliqué que les fabricants des parce
que moi ça tu m'expliques le truc des
fabricants d après je suis plus
impressionné mais je te l'expliquer
thala oui
c'est vrai c'est vraiment le bleu
pourquoi je vous l'expliquais avant
parce que je sais que tout le monde se
dit ouais mais si tu expliques tel truc
les gens ils vont le comprendre sur
câble retenant pas du tout alors qu'en
fait tu fais pas le lien tout de suite
quoi tu vois c'est pas si évident que ça
surtout les chercheurs c'est dans vos
pas vous avez fabien olicard laissez moi
car il fait le tour du coup ça va c'est
vrai on passe à la suite
entraînez-vous pour le faire entre deux
parties de jeux de société c'est
vraiment bluffant d'ailleurs vous pouvez
faire remarquer la particularité concédé
les deux faces opposées sont toujours
égale à 7 ça ne vous empêchera pas de
les bleus fait quand même avec ce tour
pourtant basé dessus
dans ce c'est à vous de spécialités et
des blocages de cerveau il n'y aura pas
de test sur du savoir mais bien trois
pari amusant qui était beaucoup utilisé
dans les bars pour s'amuser ou pour
arnaquer les autres et se faire payer un
coût gratuitement vous êtes prêts c'est
parti
ou trois paris de comptoir oui on
appelle ça des bérets quand toi vous
n'êtes pas obligé de le faire à un
comptoir quelque part
oui je sais pas dans leurs deux dans
quelle heure je vais les faire en vrai
c'est des trucs était vraiment fait dans
les bars soit pour gagner un billet sur
pour faire payer un premier pari de
comptoir je prends un billet de 20
je pose le vert sur le publier de 20
donc on imagine c'est un verre plein
d'un liquide parce que tu es dans les
mares et le défi est le suivant tu dois
enlever le billet est arrivé en belgique
et il est à toi ou je te paye un coup et
c'est toi sinon celle inverse donc tu
dois réussir à enlever le billet sans
toucher au vert sans toucher à la table
sans utiliser un autre objet ok tu dois
quand même récupérer ce billet comment
faire
hé bé c'est très bien c'est pas du tout
la solution attendue s'est extrêmement
bien ok alors c'est quand il s'agit
d'argent clairement c'est validé c'était
quoi la vraie la vraie technique c'est
pas ça sais-tu comme tu as le droit de
toucher au but en fait j'ai enroulé de
billets sur lui-même apurer pas débile
et délicatement ou alors nettement moins
risqué donc fait cette technique en
réalité nettement moins risqué et là tu
peux l'emporter mais après tu te dis
attend si jamais la personne a réussi
son pari ce qui vient de se passer avec
toi et tu dis ok quitte ou double quitte
ou double je lui ai dit qu'ils tout cas
moi je te dis benzing double hockey en
double maintenant je te donne un
deuxième défi tu vois la tête de verre
puis je te demander s'il te plaît de
faire tenir le vert sur ce billet
évidemment tu n'as pas le droit à ce que
le le billet touche les autres vers tu
n'as pas le droit d'utiliser d'autres
accessoires tu n'as pas le droit de dire
voilà ça tient faut que tu trouve une
solution qui fait que tu peux te poser
tout l'ensemble et le vert tient sur le
billet qui est posé sur les deux vers
la fois que ça tienne
je te laisse travailler à toute visée
maintenu la tête et hop
comme si ça avait un impact
comptable aimante j'aurais fait autre
chose comme ça
j'ai attendu que ça marchait bien
non spontanément j'aurais fait quelque
chose comme ça mais je les ai dit le
vert n'a pas le droit de toucher les
deux autres vers
sata le droit solution oui ok tu prends
ton billet et tu vas faire comme moi tu
le repli un peu mais j'avais une
particulier ah bah oui bon
ok mais alors oui je fais une petite
échelle fait un petit tu fais un petit
accordéon alors non j'arrête à penser
qu'en fait on va faire de l'
architecture c'est exactement comme ça
qu'on construit un pont on va faire de
la répartition des forces n'a
complètement imaginer le viaduc de
millau comme ça exactement et de mêler
deux
abbaoui et je fais ça exactement et ça
ne tient pas alors toi tu tues tu as
fait tu as fait un petit peu trop large
toit j'ai fait un tout petit peu plus en
fait ok si tu ne laisses bien serré et
qui fait bien des petits plis tu peux
laisser et ya pas de danger assez
incroyable je le vis bleus fait un
partout la balle au centre d'un parcours
balancement car alors double ou triple a
les tripes parce que c'est pas mon
argent
le troisième paris c'est un de mes
préférés ça se passe avec un jeu de
cartes ya toujours un jeu de cartes
pourri dans les choquer au club c'est le
cas aussi
il peut ne pas être complet il peut être
crasseux et que tu peux ne pas savoir
manipuler les cartes que comme tu peux
le constater ce n'est pas un souci tu
peux contrôler des cartes à la demande
tu fais ce que tu veux j'ai claqué des
doigts quand tu claque des doigts ça
fait partir des cartes c'est incroyable
sessegnon lui plus de matière grise
regardez moi bien
bref
c'est la vignette
je choisis une carte tels que tu veux je
ne regarde pas évidemment tu prends le
temps de la regarder de la faire voir
une caméra et après tu me regardes et tu
l'as reposent ici quand ces prêts c'est
bon je repose ici tu as ta carte en tête
oui c'est un pari si le le double ou
triple ok donc moi je vais essayer de
retrouver ta carte ton but c'est que je
la retrouve pas du hockey sauf que toi
là tu l'as déjà ma carte est bien
absolument pas attention faut que tu me
donne aucun indice à aucun moment
évidemment je pense qu'elle n'est pas là
mais je te regarde pas je ne veux aucun
indice pour le moment il ya un moment
donné je sais que j'aurai un flash c'est
sûr
je pense que la prochaine carte que je
vais retourner c'est ta carte ok pari
tenu
ok
ok comment des faits qui est triple j'ai
tellement gfr à oui alors donc c'était
un peu corner pas du tout le truc que je
voulais faire c'était un pari que tout
le monde puisse refaire très facilement
non pas d'entraînement du tout du tout
et ne pas dévoiler les grands tours des
magiciens donc j'ai pris le truc le plus
basique que font les enfants est ce que
je peux te donner ma suspicion tu a
séparé le nombre de cartes droite et
gauche quand tu m'as dit remet la carte
dans le paquet à compter le nombre de
cartes non puis simple away
de carthage en effet est ce que tu crois
que naît ce vieux truc d'enfants ou on
te dit choisi une carte wi
vas-y repose là et moi pendant ce temps
là je regarde celle-ci jeu-là memories
et je sais que c'est la suivante c'est
exactement ce que j'ai fait mais il ya
pas mal de gens qui ont fait ça est en
petit ils connaissent ce truc de raser
bon tu l'as vu tu sais donc ce que j'ai
fait c'est que j'ai dis regarde je ferme
les yeux je soulève une partie du paquet
et toi pendant ce temps-là tu remets ta
carte mais moi pendant ce temps là j'ai
fait quoi j'ai ouvert un oeil parce que
vraiment de mon côté on voit extrêmement
bien la carte oui donc mais toi comme tu
le vois pas t'as pas trop conscience que
je la vois je dit vasile repose takhar
épouse mme akar et donc moi là je vois
très bien la carte là après je referme
les yeux pour dire c'est bon je peux
reposer je ferme et toi tu dit il babula
car c'était de l'acting c'était que de
l'acting et ensuite il suffit de les
retourner laisse sur le bluff je
retourne je retourne une fois que je
vois ma carte clé on appelle ça donc
c'était le de trèfle je sais que la
carte suivante c'est ta carte je la mets
un peu à l'écart gens posent encore et
c'est là où encore on à du bluff et de
la king même tu sais de la prochaine
carte que je retournais c'est la tienne
je te le pari en plus tu ta pote le
paquet donc la personne se dit alors là
il a rien compris
et toi tu prends la carte de la personne
tue la retourne pas rythme dingue
incroyable assez bluffant c'est très
impressionnant bah si mais c'est trop
marrant à faire et le dernier petit
conseil qu'on peut donner c'est bête
plus vous allez levez un gros pack et
plus ça va durer mille ans pour rien
donc en fait il n'était pas à lever un
petit paquet de 10 15 cartes vous lever
comme ça vous allez hop vous flashez
votre carte vous reposer ça t'a plu
c'était fabuleux tu le feras ton père
oui qui aiment les livres pas encore il
ne connaît pas tes livres lisant je vais
lui donner cet été pour qu'ils les
booking pour qu'ils les sur lignon jeu
qui ne vous fait ça et dites moi dans
les commentaires si ç'a fonctionné ou
pas nous on passe à l'action
[Musique]
voilà comment on peut faire fonctionner
son cerveau l'été en travaillant les
illusions de logique générés par le
cerveau comme pour les paris impossibles
qui sont pourtant évident dès lors que
l'on pense en dehors de la boîte des
consignes qu'on nous avait donné au
départ
c'est sûrement l'un des jeux les plus
célèbres au monde tout le monde a essayé
de gagner à ce jeu en trouvant ses
propres petites techniques et
aujourd'hui je vais y inclure deux
choses la logique mathématique et de la
mauvaise foi pour la mauvaise foi je ne
vais pas essayer sur le là parce que je
sais que ça ne va pas du tout passé avec
elle pourtant il existe une faille dans
la règle du quiès la question inclusive
multiples n'est pas interdite dans le
règlement officiel du qui s assit vous
pouvez dire est ce qu'ils les blonds ou
roux ou avec des lunettes si l'autre
joueur dit non vous pouvez en un seul
coup enlever toutes les personnes qui
sont rouges ou blancs donc ou qui ont
des lunettes et si l'autre joueur dit
oui alors dans ces cas là vous ne gardez
que les personnes qui sont blondes ou
rousses ou qui ont des lunettes c'est
pas très fair play mais c'est légal mais
bon comme ça passe pas avec tout le
monde heureusement pour nous il y à
aussi la détection des récurrences
donc le but de cette expérience 4 sait
comment gagner aux pièces c'est à dire
le credo est certainement pas
on peut gagner d'une manière certaine en
cinq coups et tu vas me dire oui mais
fabien ça enlève l'intérêt de jouer oui
y'a pas de fabien on est là pour gagner
là que pour gagner on n'est pas là pour
prendre du plaisir ou pour essayer des
choses on est là pour gagner en cinq
coups ok donc pour l'instant je vais
jouer une technique toi tu joues pas ce
que tu veux comme technique et on verra
si tu gagnes avant moi ou pas déjà ok on
pioche chacun un personnage on le on le
met ici pour que la caméra le vois bien
et honneur aux invités je te laisserais
commence alors
est ce que c'est un homme
c'est un homme
est donc là tu vois qu'avec la mauvaise
répartition hommes-femmes à vous c'est
l'un des premiers qui s est vraiment
ridicule loin ils ont décidé de mettre
en avant plutôt les hommes blancs
caucasien maintenant ils ont réglé ça
évidemment les plus représentatifs de
notre société ma question à moi c est ce
que dans le prénom de ton personnage
dans les trois premières lettres du
prénom de ton personnage qu'est ce qu'un
à trois points donc non donc ça peut pas
être anita ça peut pas être ça ça peut
être maxime et albert ça peut pas être
maria salissa peut pas être en deçà peut
être charles paul non plus
voilà comment se passe ce jeu je te
donne un peu la technique déjà utilisée
c'est de trouver comment diviser en deux
à chaque fois si tu divises 1,2 à chaque
fois tu passeras de 24 à 12 de 12 à 6
2,6 à 3,3 à ces boat belle technique gtz
et termina donc quoi mais par contre
c'est un peu triptyque tu vois parce
qu'ils n'ont pas bien répartie des trucs
genre t'as que cinq personnes qui ont
des lunettes ou des choses comme ça donc
il faut trouver des choses en plus en
fait des choses qui n'existent pas comme
là pour les lettres voilà tu sais ce que
tu veux de ce que je veux dire et je te
laisse jouer moi je joue à la technique
classique ok est ce que ton personnage
porte une barbe ou moustache
absolument pas donc on dit au revoir à
mario ont dit au revoir à bill à max à
charles et à hand femmes à ce cher inde
c'est évidemment violentes est ce qu'un
haut dans le prénom de ton personnage
oui oui un os au revoir bill au revoir
betty au revoir bernard au revoir eric
au revoir liouc freddy heirman et voilà
en deux coups il m'en reste bien 6 donc
j'ai toujours bien tout divisé par deux
est ce que ton personnage souris eh bien
je dirais oui est ce que c'est un oui
franc c'est un ours étaient en vie
correcte ce serait mensonger de dire que
mon personnage ne sourit pas
ok pas mal sans technique aboutie quand
même à 4 au dernier coup c'est non c'est
très bien même ça ne m'arrange pas alors
je vais te demander moi est ce que ton
personnage elle et a les cheveux
châtains non non
je m'en tiens ma technique mathématique
je suis passé de 24 à 12 de 12 à 6 2 6 à
3 voix ça ça fonctionne bien est ce que
ton personnage a les yeux bleus
absolument pas
j'ai pas puis j'avais pas de possibilité
de questions j'ai pas assez de vie moi
je vais te demander si est-ce que ce
personnage a les cheveux blancs oui
ok l'étau se resserre est ce que ton
personnage a des grosses lèvres des
lèvres enfin j'entends une grande bouche
combourieu correct oui ne surent bloc en
bouche tu as gagné est ce que le
personnage a un chapeau oui et je m'en
doutais depuis deux tours c'était jo
c'était chaud c'est les mains et mme
claire t qui moi je pense que c'est tu
as victor et 7 franck amincie j'avais
franck est pourquoi je m'en doutais
depuis deux tours alors là c'est plus
des maths c'est presque du mentalisme
c'est quand je t'ai demandé s'il était
châtain tafer
et comme il a le chapeau et qu'on voit
pas très bien c'est chou en dessous je
me suis
choqué de temps pas le temps en fait le
temps est donc alors qu'est ce que c'est
que c'était alors qu'est-ce que voilà
qu'est ce qu'elle montre cette technique
elle montre que les maths nous
permettent de toujours gagner alors
habité
y'a aucun charme à jouer à ça vous
pouvez prendre dix minutes pour jouer
mais il faut absolument que votre
question permettent d'éliminer à coup
sûr la moitié et si tu te réfères pas
l'émotionnel c'est à dire que si tu te
chauffe pas de temps en temps à essayer
un truc tu es dans le dans le nombre de
parties que tu feras tu sera beaucoup
plus gagnant que perdants parce que même
moi un moment donné j'ai coûte quand
même passer devant tu vois pas ce que
j'avais quand même pas mal taper dans
avait 5 ans il me restait 6 mai mais en
fait le truc assez froid de me dire ok
il faut que je trouve un élément
différenciant à chaque fois pour diviser
par deux ça fonctionne on se fiche des
prénoms c'est assez forte et voilà tout
tout marche avec le truc des prénoms qui
est un truc auquel on pense jamais mais
tu as toujours des éléments
différenciants ceux qui terminent par
une voyelle ou pas ce qu'ils contiennent
un ou pas là quand je voulais faire le
truc des as au début je me suis à temps
j'en ai 14 avec un à alger qu'à demander
si le a et dans les trois premières
lettres en fait 12 12 et puis après tu
peux pas ce que je vais dire est ce
qu'on peut se dire est ce que c'est un
prénom cours quatre lettres par exemple
ouais bah ça fonctionne ça merci
lola-judd bini mais avec plaisir ces
j'ai passé un très bon moment et franck
aussi franck aussi ouais on invite pour
le prochain match à beslon merci fabien
olicard de m'avoir invité
puisqu'il ya vingt quatre personnages la
seule technique qui permet de gagner en
cinq coups et celle des récurrences à
chaque coup on doit éliminer la moitié
des personnages de boue cependant les
différentes versions du qui est ce la
plupart des spécificités sont attribués
à cinq personnages maximum 5 ans des
lunettes cinq sont blonds cinq sont
rouges etc en demandant si le personnage
à la lettre à dans les trois premières
lettres de son prénom je vais
automatiquement éliminés 12 sur les 24
il faut donc prendre son temps à chaque
tour pour être certain d'avoir la
question qui vous fera éliminer à chaque
fois la moitié du plateau vous allez
donc passé de 24 à 12 à 6 à 3 puis à 2
en seulement 4
merci à tous les participants à toute
l'équipe à fannie et jérémie à la
production à loïc à la réalisation avec
toute son équipe est bien sûr à l'aula
du business n'hésitez pas à découvrir
ces vidéos le gain est dans la
description vous pouvez partager cette
vidéo la laïque et vous abonner
gratuitement à cette chaîne et si la
série vous plaît sachez que vous avez
les neuf épisodes précédents dans la
description avec une playlist alors
avons nous fait le temps de matière
grise sommes-nous sûrs d'avoir vu tout
ce qu'il y avait à comprendre sur le
cerveau y aura-t-il une saison 2 de
matière grise nous aurons la réponse à
tout cela et bien plus dans le dernier
épisode de matière grise en septembre à
très bientôt ciao